[Musik]
knallige autos flattern die petticoats
und mitreißende musik die rock'n roll
ära von elvis presley eroberte die welt
im sturm und begeistert fans noch heute
[Musik]
ich bin in cleveland ohio und der nähe
der rock'n'roll hall of fame
aufgewachsen von kleiner für elvis für
mich der king of rock n roll
ich wusste nicht dass er auch in
deutschland gelebt hat erst recht nicht
in dieser kleinen stadt die jedes jahres
europäische elvis festival veranstaltet
ich will wissen was hier so los ist
elvis presley wurde 1958 auf dem
höhepunkt seiner karriere von der us
armee eingezogen und in der deutschen
stadt friedberg stationiert
der benachbarte ort bad nauheim in
hessen sollte für rund anderthalb jahre
sein zuhause werden
heute legt die stadt den rest der welt
zum siebzehnten europäischen elvis
festival ein
mal gucken ob sie den geist von elvis
und rock'n roll heraufbeschwören kann
drei tage lang dreht sich in bad nauheim
alles um den king of rock n roll mit
autos mode musik und tanz aus den 50er
jahren
was begeistert die festivalbesucher
heute noch an dieser ära man kann sich
schön anziehen man kann schön tanzen
das macht spaß augen schaue ich häufig
toller mann toller sänger toller
entertainer
meine frau steht auf den look von elvis
und teilnehmer genauso die haare
menschen wir sind denen die musik
wichtig ist das finde ich toll weil
dadurch lebt es halt auch weiter
die meisten der musiker hier sind keine
elvis imitatoren
allerdings ist er für sie nach wie vor
eine große künstlerische inspiration
[Musik]
auch für die grammy gewinnerin li na die
einst gemeinsam mit dem king auf der
bühne stand
[Musik]
für die elvis party am abend sind
tanzkünste gefragt
[Musik]
spätestens am zweiten festivaltag haben
der stadt tausende elvis-fans das sagen
dieses auto erinnert an den berühmten
rosa cadillac des sängers der war
bekannt dafür anzuhalten um autogramme
zu geben was ihm den namen elvis das
verkehrshindernis einbrachte das war
übrigens nicht das einzige mal dass er
in schwierigkeiten geriet hotelmanager
thomas dröscher erzählt warum der king
und seine gesamte entourage nach nur
wenigen monaten aus dem hotel grunewald
rausgeworfen wurden
der hauptgrund war dass die zeitungen
angezündet und dann das feuer
ausgeblasen haben das rauchen papier
haben sie dann für andere zimmer gelegt
und fanden es lustig als die alten damen
ausgelaufen sind und dachten das hotel
würde bremm
irgendwann hat er hotel besitzt er dann
gesagt okay jetzt reicht es heute können
fans ab 150 euro pro nacht in dem
original erhaltenen zimmer übernachten
normalerweise freundlich gut gelaunt und
lustig oder sie weinend vor glück
gestern war eine frau die aber das bett
geküsst offensichtlich brauchte der kind
eine menge spiegel um sich zu stylen
allein in diesem zimmer sind sechs davon
fast überall wird man in bad nauheim an
elvis presley erinnert besucher können
während einer geführten tour in seine
fußstapfen treten
der rundgang führt auch an seinem haus
in der goethestraße 14 vorbei in dem er
seine spätere ehefrau priscilla buyout
auf einer party kennen lernte das haus
wurde damals ständig von fans aus aller
welt belagert dass elvis festival nähert
sich dem ende
fans haben bei mehr als 50
veranstaltungen ihr idol gefeiert